you
nearly fifty percent of our incoming
students this year our female this is
phenomenal I mean many places it's just
the teens even lower teens so I think
this is a very memorable event where
we're really have leveled leveled the
playing field
so in in the electrical and computer
engineering department at Carnegie
Mellon we we have looked at an overall
strategy to diversify our environment
it's really important to understand that
you cannot do anything in isolation and
research shows that diverse groups
perform better so anything that we can
do to explain to people that it's not
only the work we do but the atmosphere
and the culture we do it in and that's
very important I think I actually got my
first interest in engineering from a
program i did actually here at carnegie
mellon when I was in Middle School it's
called the summer engineering experience
for girls learning that CMU has such a
well-respected programming chemical
engineering it just seems like a really
good fit at Dean of computer science and
drew more when I came to visit he
actually was able to meet me and talk
further about my opportunities here and
how I could combine the different
subjects I was interested in it seemed
like I could achieve great things here
so that really pushed me to Sam you
there's a very broad aspect to computer
science and to get people to understand
that early on will help guide them into
the appropriate courses at the high
school level we organized workshops for
high school teachers where we wrote them
into Carnegie Mellon during the summer
and we taught them a wider perspective
of computer science its priming the
pipelines of so to speak we address the
issue what happens once students get
here they have to to have an environment
that's going to nurture them and help
them succeed and so we have made again a
concentrated effort to increase contact
students have with faculty especially in
sort of non classroom settings so they
have a feeling we are people too and we
can have fun we have also started
pairing our undergraduate women with our
female alums and that helps with career
advice with networking with mentoring
and basically building the support
system for after they graduate as well I
really likes EMU because it was very
active in increasing the number
then it was incorporating woman it was
incorporating a lot of underrepresented
groups I felt like this would be a
community where I could grow and really
achieve what I wanted to do so it's
really critical for women to be at the
table and in particular it's critical
for women to have the technical skills
to be able to create the future